my name is Arthur Mutambara and one of
the leaders of the Opposition in
Zimbabwe the Movement for Democratic
Change is with two formations and then
one of the presidents of those two
formations I think my background in
Zimbabwe my history in Zimbabwe shapes
my understanding of the world you know
growing up under the legal regime of Ian
Smith as a young person I witnessing the
armed struggle to liberate Zimbabwe and
then witnessing the independence for
country 1980 and then going to school in
an independent Zimbabwe and then
witnessing the deterioration of the
nation online African government the
corruption the dictatorship of Gabon in
the 80s and 90s in particular my
experience as a student and inverse of
Zimbabwe and then beyond that then
living the country to go to school at
Oxford and so my history and experiences
ABAB way is what ships my understanding
of the world and understanding of the
challenges that we have in this world
and also my understanding of the
solutions to the problems
as a young person growing up read quite
a lot and I was inspired by people like
Malcolm X fought for civil rights in
this country I was inspired by people
like Che Guevara a medical doctor who
fought for the liberation of people in
Cuba when he was an adjutant and then
after achieving independence in freedom
in Cuba he went on to continue with
revolution in in Bolivia and was killed
in 67 so a men like Che Guevara is a
source of inspiration for me why because
of the dedication commitment and
sacrifice that he epitomizes and then
Malcolm because he was a strong black
leader in this country who challenged
the system in this country and spoke
truth to power in the United States so
Malcolm X and Che Guevara two
individuals that have inspired me and
also I source of inspiration and Mandela
at a lower level is another you know
hero that inspires my work I was at
front of history and English and the
arts but I deliberately decided to study
the sciences and mathematics so that
I'll be the Renaissance man as to do
history as to do his English as to do
current affairs because I was very
passionate about those things but out
pursue or then pursue engineering and
science so at the end of the day I would
end up understanding politics philosophy
and economics and at the same time
understanding rocket science engineering
and mathematics
so I decided deliberately to cut the
life of Renaissance man
you